how does it feel to be a part of the
Yellowstone universe
well I don't know yet I mean I mean I'm
seeing the film for the first time today
yeah
I know what lengths
that Tim McGraw has gone to protect his
family Kevin Costner has gone to protect
his family
at what lengths will Jacob Dutton go to
protect his family and his land
as far as it takes
[Applause]
you attack my family it's gonna be the
last thing you ever do
now of course in 1923 you get to reunite
alongside Helen Mirren 36 years after
the last time you two starred together
how great was it to reunite with Ellen
that's great great fun I mean she's
wonderful
wonderful person and a fantastic actress
and it's just a pleasure to
to work with her again see you again
everyone has been singing your Praises
tonight too of a what a wonderful human
you are to work alongside too and also
what a horse rider you are I'm hearing
that
well why don't you ask a horse about
that
he'll be 23 yeah and the Indiana Jones
trailer your fans are so excited this
weekend but I want to talk about this
trailer for a second they did not need
to digitally de-age you my friend but
they did what was your reaction when you
first saw that this is a different kind
of dag
[Music]
archival footage of film of me at that
age
so it's not it's not that it's a
different process it's pretty remarkable
I blew me away
[Music]